let me start with Mike Florio Pro
Football Talk just finished his show
kind enough to join us in mike has some
hot takes but let me start with this do
you like the Kansas City Chiefs or do
you love the Kansas City Chiefs
I love the Kansas City Chiefs during the
regular season I don't know what to make
of the Kansas City Chiefs come the
playoffs right because they we had that
narrative with the Bengals they can't
win in the postseason I mean the Chiefs
have that same tendency they struggle to
win it how do I ever lose at home look
at that beam last night how do they ever
lose a game there and they consistently
find ways to lose in the postseason so
it's going to be even more pressure than
the higher they finish in the playoff
tree if there's a one-seater the to see
we're going to be hearing plenty about
how the Chiefs can't get it done at home
and who's going to go in there and
possibly knock them off and it's amazing
that they have struggles and this year
they probably have their best team on
paper that they've had maybe since they
won the Super Bowl and not a lot of
weaknesses I like what they can do but I
need to see them prove it when the when
the games count and that's not going to
be until January are yet a couple of hot
takes on pro football talk let me start
with the hottest one and that is
depending on how long Marcus Mariota is
out Derek Carr we know is out for a
couple of weeks with a fracture in his
back you thought maybe bringing in Colin
Kaepernick certainly for Tennessee makes
sense why we know I'm one of the one of
the narratives that was out there back
when we were in this mode where people
were actually trying to sell the idea
that was only football reasons that
Colin Kaepernick didn't have a job
before Steve bisciotti the Ravens owner
pretty made it much made it clear to
everyone that it's not just football
reasons one of the arguments was Colin
Kaepernick style is dramatically
different from the starter so he can't
be the backup because you need a backup
he's just like starter meanwhile in
Tennessee you got Matt Cassel backing up
Marcus Mariota are you kidding me he
should have been there all along
Kaepernick should have been there all
along and he's the guy that if Mariota
this is some time and even if he doesn't
miss time now with this hamstring injury
he has the kind of playing style that is
conducive to other injuries yet the
broken leg last December and it just it
would have made sense for the Titans to
have a backup if there's anything to
this notion that you want to have a
backup who can simulate what your
starter does so there's minimum drop-off
change if the guy gets injured then it
should have been Kaepernick all along
instead of Matt cast but you know that
President Trump is going to send out a
tweet if you do that you know right away
he's already done that with Colin
Kaepernick and this is a state that
voted I think over 60% for Donald Trump
I just can't see them employing him even
though they need a better backup
quarterback Mike after everything that's
happened over the last 11 days though
with this I I don't have to get worse at
this point right I mean it's already
Trump versus the NFL and that's subsided
for obvious reasons in the past couple
of days but at some point it's going to
come back again but it's have to ask
yourself well what are we in the
business of doing here I mean yes you
want to have your fans show up but you
want them to support your team you only
want to win games and that's the way to
secure long-term support national
following win football games and the
Titans are kind of on the cusp of that
but if they don't have an adequate
backup to Mariota and whether it's now
or whether it's week ten and he misses
time and they lose just enough games
that they don't make it to the playoffs
you've blown your opportunity to make
your team into one of those teams that
people want to follow and I just think
for that reason you need to have a
backup it feel good about and and and I
look I don't know there was a sense
immediately in the aftermath of what the
president said that this means somebody
is going to go out and sign Colin
Kaepernick and there's been no interest
in him at the 10 days since then but I
just think that when you look at the
Titans you look at Mariota if you can't
play Kaepernick makes so much more sense
than Matt Cassel and and if you're
making a football decision that would
seem to be the right decision Mike
Florio Pro Football Talk joining us yeah
but my issue I think if you ask it be an
interesting result interesting poll
question if you ask fans in Tennessee
would you rather bring in Kaepernick
knowing he'll make your team better or
would you rather stay status quo I'm
curious if even though they Kaepernick
might be a better backup quarterback or
even filling in for a couple of games if
they would still rather stay status quo
yeah if that's the only question asked
and they're not lumping in all the other
issues College other questions then
you're probably going to have people say
we don't want anything to do with
college happen it just because that's a
Weedle
yourself in this on going to face but it
broadened so much when the president
said what he said and or players decided
to protest that it at one hand you know
you look at and it underscores Colin
Patrick's role as starting this I think
it also dilutes his role in what has
become a much bigger movement a much
bigger issue than him and who knows but
the point is you want to win games matt
cassel versus colin kaepernick to tell
an EJ Manuel versus Colin Titanic yeah I
think we all know the answer to that one
to Adrian Peterson if you were the
Vikings you would you would call to see
if maybe you could get Adrian Peterson
back due to the injury to Dalvin cook
yeah I know there's a history there and
there's some hard feelings given the way
it all ended that they were gonna paint
18 million for this year if they had
another contract for three million for
this year I think he'd still be in
Minnesota so if they could get him under
contract for three million and if he'd
happily do it if you accept the fact
he's not going to get 25 carries a game
if he'd be happy with 15 to 20 which
would be a heck of a lot more than what
he's gotten in New Orleans so far he's
got 27 in four games 16 games a full
season in 10 years of Minnesota where he
had 27 or more carries in a single game
so I I would I'd like to think that
people can be mature and be adults and
let bygones be bygones and set
everything aside and understand he knows
the personnel he knows the coaches he's
got a comfort level there that he
wouldn't have anywhere else he could hit
the ground running for the Vikings and
without Calvin Cooke they need something
in wrote a US Marine Jared Kenny
McKinnon aren't what they need it's one
of those things where it makes too much
sense and it involves too much ego
setting aside to ever happen the my LA
Rams are they are they the best team in
the division right now they are now
whether or not they can hold that
remains you see one of the things about
Pete Carroll and I think this is what
sets Pete Carroll and Bill Belichick
apart from their peers they know how to
make a team better on the fly and
whatever flaws a team has in September
they're going to get ironed out by
November in December and the team is
going to be better and that makes them
relative to their competition in
position
to rise up and we're gonna find out this
weekend break game this weekend
Seattle on the Rams get together we'll
see what Pete Carroll can do because the
Rams have had good luck against the
Seahawks in recent years in comparison
to what the Seahawks have done to other
teams but I think the ranch still have
to worry about the Seahawk they don't
have to wear out the Cardinals or the
49ers and if Seattle gets better on the
fly that could be the team that
ultimately knocks the Rams off the top
spot that division the Patriots defense
you talked about Belichick adapting you
know almost quarter to quarter in game
but you know this is a bad bad secondary
who who would have thought you would
have thought the secondary would be the
strength of the Patriots and the issue
would be that they can they stop the run
or can they put pressure on the
quarterback
what has how do you fix this in New
England well I think you have to keep it
simple that's something Rodney Harrison
and Tony Dungy both said on Sunday and
this is an example Dan of where Bill
Belichick the personnel evaluator makes
it harder on Bill Belichick the head
coach because they knew Stephane Gilmore
they played against the pond gilmore
twice a year for five years and I
thought hey this is genius they're
paying this time market value early days
of free agency something that Patriots
rarely do unless they really love a guy
so they must know that this guy's going
to be great and it's going to work and
this is the thing that's going to make
them be 19 and oh and it hasn't worked
yet and now Bill Belichick the head
coach is cursing Bill Belichick the
personnel evaluate all the money to this
guy and now I got to fix your mess
though belt check the personnel
evaluator so look if you took the worst
defense in the NFL whoever it is any
give it day and you say give me one
coach who I can count on to fix this
over the balance of the season that
coach you're going to take his Bill
Belichick so he gets a chance to do it
with his own defense and and yeah how
could we saw what happened three years
ago when we wrote them off when they got
blown out by the Chiefs on Monday Night
Football and I don't think anybody's
writing them off because they know Bill
Belichick is going to find a way to make
this team better thank you Mike great
stuff we appreciate your time all right
thank you that's Mike Florio Pro
Football Talk the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience